heads up guys my name is eterno and
welcome to the very first actual real
episode of the sparky engine so this is
being streamed live on twitch.tv for
Sasha Jono so if you want to tune in for
future episodes you may certainly do so
but this episode we're going to start
with making the engine we're going to
make a brand new visual studio project
and just basically start from scratch
and it should be a very good time so I
noticed a few comments from a lot of you
asking whether I would kind of plan out
what I'm going to do in front of videos
and maybe every like five videos or
something I would kind of just give you
guys a general plan so we are going to
do that because one thing I want
everyone here to realize I already did
this anyway one thing I want everyone
else to realize is that this is
completely live it's even being live
streamed so it's it's even it's a whole
new definition of live I've never
written this code before well I've
written similar code before obviously
otherwise that would be weird but I
haven't actually I don't have this
pre-written engine somewhere I'm just
going to kind of this isn't like
standard tutorial series this is me
writing an engine live and you guys
watching and hopefully learning a lot
from it so that being said yeah so I'll
be doing stuff like planning in front of
you guys because I need to do that
anyway so so let's begin so um what
we're going to do this episode ah is
start everything but we're probably
going to focus on a kind of window slash
OpenGL kind of library framework context
provider all of those things right so I
don't want to kind of not use a library
for this I don't want to just use the
win32 api and whatever the Coco Mac kind
of thing or whatever because I remember
I do want this engine to be
cross-platform but I also do not want to
waste time especially because it's like
this is a lot and air engine and let
them there is it's in like thirty six
days ish so it's we're running out of
time basically and also I don't want to
rewrite the contacts creation based on
the platform I'm on so I'm just going to
use a library for that right so we
basically got two options we've got SDL
so a simple direct media layer and it's
what that stands for
and then GL FW no clue what that stands
for but um
graphic slave fun I don't know what the
W stands for and I made that up but
anyway so we've got these two to choose
from basically so if you guys are know
what these are you should probably
research it I'm not going to probably
explain tons of it here but yeah so SDL
is they did okay so that they both do
what we want right that's why this is
going to be a kind of tough choice right
they both provide us with a window in
which opengl can run and we can rent -
okay which is our massive target okay
they also provide us with stuff like
input handling and even STL even has
some cool stuff looking like controllers
and whatnot and what else that's
probably around here so they don't do a
huge amount right SDL though does have
its own kind of rendering api's and you
can for example be like SDL render me a
rectangle right but you know I like to
render my own rectangles personally so
that's a feature of SDL that we won't be
using which makes me which makes me kind
of question it because it's like well do
we need a library this complex this
large if we're not going to be using
most of its features so the answer is no
right so I'm leaning towards lfw just
because it does everything we need out
of SDL and that's about it
it doesn't do too much extra right which
is why it's probably going to be an
easier choice because it is a smaller
framework if there are bugs in or if
there's if something goes wrong if we
want to modify it or something it'll be
much easier because it's less complex
right and we won't have to waste too
much time so this is the plan now the
other consideration we have to make when
choosing a framework such as this is its
compatibility with M scripting so M
scripting is a fantastic little thing
its magical really that arm will
basically compile you or convert your
C++ code into JavaScript code so
essentially it's going to make your C++
application run inside a web browser we
want this game mentioned to run inside a
web browser so we'll be using M
scripting we need to talk about its
compatibility
where these two now the good news is is
compatible with both of them okay which
makes this a bit less of a decision
however I believe it is slightly more
compatible with SDL simply because STL
is more popular than GL fw because it
does more and people are lazy these days
so they probably prefer this because
does more for them but anyway the point
is yes Krypton does work with both of
these in my limited time before this
series I did run a few tests of GL fw on
M scripting and it seemed to work fine
if I recall correctly so it there
shouldn't be a massive problem ok with
yellow W so we are going to start using
GL f w that's kind of what I've decided
ok and worst comes to worst if something
doesn't work out within scripting the
code we'll be using from GL FW it's
probably only going to be a total of
less than a hundred lines of actual code
so it'll be really easy to switch it
into STL if worse comes to worse so
really there's not much downside so
that's the idea yeah other other than
that there's also the fact that SDL
supports software and ring and like
DirectX and everything and M script um
sorry GL fw is just an open GL framework
so I mean it just makes sense to use it
since spark it will be an OpenGL engine
ok cool
so what are we going to begin with and
pressing this little button on my pen
but um we're going to begin with making
we're going to begin with making the
rendering engine so what we're going to
do today is we're going to download and
get GL FW to work so based on that
whoops we're going to create a window
and probably a bit of a nice kind of API
slash class that will set up windows and
gel if W for us really easily and then
if we have time we're going to look at
glue which is something else we're going
to use the OpenGL extension or angular
which basically just will load modern
OpenGL functions into our game so that
we can use modern OpenGL anything past
1.1 really and of course we'll need that
because this is going to be this engine
is going to use modern OpenGL
so that's the plan for today okay we'll
probably have enough time for this I
don't imagine this will take too long
but that's kind of the plan okay
let's begin so the first thing I want to
do is open visual studio and make this
new project so this is going to be quite
exciting this will also be on github by
the way so I need to promote to like
make this repository and push it at the
end of this episode but when we start
with this new project I'm literally just
going to go on visual C++ general and I
am going to make an empty project so
we're just starting from scratch here
I'm going to call it Sparky okay and the
solution name will should be
Sparky I might actually call this Sparky
call and then change the solution name
to something like Sparky because we
might have other components in there
such as a lot of no we might we might
modularize this project in a sense and
we might actually split it up into
several projects in the future so the
call will be all the core engine stuff
so it's probably stuff like maths and
rendering and everything that is
basically the minimum that we need to
run Sparky in okay so we'll make that
we'll hit OK and then here we have our
actual setup so if we right click on
this and go open folder and file
explorer it might be useful just to look
at our directory so you can see under
projects we've got Sparky and then we've
got this fantastic
like debug database full of goodies for
the no one actually needs well we don't
need right now but we've got the
solution file and we've got core and
that's the appropriate file so you can
see we've actually got a folder called
Sparky call which is going to be all the
core engine stuff cool so let's begin so
I'm just going to right click on source
add a new file and we're going to make a
main file so this would be like a this
will be like our test kind of file if I
was feeling particularly adventurous
let's just say I could actually make a
different project called something like
game I might do this we won't bother
with this today but in the future I'll
probably make a new project called game
and then we'll actually reference the
spiky core project so that this will
only be the core the code needed for the
actual engine Ryan but I'm going to
start off with having a main in here and
way cool so we have nothing to do yet
because we need to actually grab the lfw
from the internet so I'm going to open
Chrome I want to type in GL FW and I'm
going to click on this download button
which should be fantastic and let's see
so we want a few things right by the way
this GL of W is bound into a lot of
other languages so you probably could
use all that and I think anything works
with stuff like yeah yeah there's a lot
of different bindings here anyway we
don't want any of that we want the
windows precompiled binary that's all
we'll really need so 32-bit Windows
binaries the source is also available so
we could build it ourselves of course
we're not going to do that because
there's no need if it's already been
done for us ok good so it's downloading
here it is and it's downloaded ah let's
just check okay yeah everything we need
is in here so that's fantastic so let's
grab this I'm actually going to copy
this into My Documents into Visual
Studio 2013 and then I'm actually
probably going to make a folder called
like libs or something just out here
okay and this will just have all of our
like libraries or dependencies that we
use so any anything that's external will
kind of just paste in here and then we
can this will be like an extracted
directory this won't be kind of part of
our project or anything I'm just
basically making this in fat I might
actually just put it into documents
because it really has nothing to do with
anything I'm just basically making a
folder to extract my files to so in here
let's talk about this quickly so we've
got some nice docks which I'm going to
mostly ignore we've got our lives for
visual for the visual c++ compiler 2013
which is what we're using so really
we'll only need these to write we'll
need libs for the actual project and the
DLL for running it and then we have the
include headers which we also need so
what I'm going to do is open up my other
directory which is right here so Sparky
call right outside of Sparky core ok I'm
going to make a folder called
dependencies
yeah and inside dependencies I'm going
to put all of our dependencies so in
other words I will actually be let's
just say committing them along with the
project so you guys will be able to UM
you won't have to download anything
basically we should we should get this
just working so that's kind of the plan
so inside dependencies I'm going to make
a folder called jail if they'll be which
will include all everything we need for
GL FW so for example just include
directory so I'll make include and we'll
have that then I'm basically just grab
this Lib and that's really all we'll
need so now these are actually inside
our project right cool
so let's talk about how we're going to
actually make them work I think there's
two ways we could do this with Visual
Studio we could well a we could actually
just put it into Program Files an
individual studio and then we wouldn't
even have to modify our project we can
just use it apart from adding GLW as a
additional dependency but we could make
a folder that literally just says Lib
and it has all of our different Lib
files in it so in other words we can mix
our all of our dependencies into like
one big cake and just import them into
Visual Studio in the sense that we won't
have to have separate directories for
each library so that's up to you you
could do that I'm probably not just
because I'm not not doing that I just
decided not to for some reason
but inside GL of W we have this include
directory so we want to be able to use
these so how do we do that well let's
copy this hit up properties we probably
want to actually put in to include
directories so under include directories
I probably want to actually use that
macro so let's see what we've got here
where is so we've got our solution
Direction directory so let's grab that
so I just otherwise it won't work if I
put an absolute path one word for you
got a slit from me so solution directory
I think that does have a trailing slash
our solution directory which should be
Sparky then dependencies GL fw include
so hopefully
I mean we'll see in a minute but if we
hit OK on that it should add it and if
we type in include glf Toby you can see
it is there which is good
all right cool so we've got your low W
now let's let's let's quickly make this
so what I want to do now is just Google
J left over you again and there should
be a getting started guide so this is
great so let's just look through this
quickly
there should be our putting it all
together putting it putting it together
let's just quickly we'll probably just
in it Jilla w and see if that works so
I'll also um have our brilliant iostream
so if you love W net I think zero means
bad in this case so if not jello double
unit will just print arrow so right now
we're just making which is kind of
importing G love W making sure
everything works before we move on to
other stuff success so we're just going
to make sure that everything works first
all right cool so if we run this now
well I will get errors and whatnot
because we haven't actually linked it
but cool so gel W net is our unresolved
external so if we go to properties under
library directories let's just copy this
other thing so under dependencies in
jail of W I think we've got our
fantastic Lib folder thing that will add
that ok hit OK and then under linker and
input under additional dependencies we
want to list our dependencies so what is
it so GL o w3 dot Lib there's one of
them OpenGL 32 dot level got also one
and then we'll have other stuff here
like GL e W 32 dot Levin whatever for
glue and once we get all that stuff so
that should be it for now right so if we
re compile this it should work now
it didn't which is fantastic
so we're going to have to investigate
that I actually remember this not
working I did try this recently and it
didn't work
so hopefully that that's not the era
where happening because otherwise we'll
have to recompile everything but we'll
see yeah so a bit of backstory
I am chilled with real AM pianos in
there that is in the input so one thing
we might actually have to do hopefully
not we'll see we might actually have to
change the system to be console or
something now that's not it
so fantastic we've got a Lincoln Lincoln
era when we shouldn't differently there
was a good way too deep to debug this
she'll do a three dollar lamp
alright so that's definitely included
dependencies gia left IV yep let me just
ah see this is why I like live streaming
it because I can see that I'm in the
wrong configuration for some reason so
make sure you're in the right
configuration does that mean how did
Lowell so the reason the include
probably worked was because I probably
got it in my visual studio directory so
that was it just - that was just a fluke
there so make sure you're in the right
configuration again I don't know why it
opens with the wrong one but make sure
you're in the right configuration and
then you want to go to your include
directories and basically do everything
we've done so we could just copy and
paste it of course from the release so
let's copy and paste that and yes I do
want to save changes and then same with
library and then of course
same with yes same with our input there
you go alright so now no linking errors
fantastic
cool so what we want to do now and yeah
we're getting these okay so I what I
should do is basically go into program
files and delete JFW from
where are we and delete GL fw from
everywhere basically so from include and
in lib as well so delete those two
actually alright yeah so we will just
get rid of that stuff so that we don't
get stuff like possible conflicts and
whatnot
and then we should get a successful
build and if we run this and we pause it
it should work okay
success fantastic so now the GL it'll be
is all working we can probably move on
to actually making this window class and
that is the next step so let's go ahead
and just use this show all files window
here we'll create a new folder we could
have done that in the other view
obviously but alcohol it sauce okay and
then under source I'm going to make a
new folder called graphics right and
then I'm going to make a new item right
called window dot age it's going to be a
header file so this is going to be all
about fun stuff from for our window
class so we'll also probably make a C+
or file while rounded called window cool
so there you go put these guys side by
side like I keep forgetting that I
probably should shouldn't be doing that
because of the FaceCam so I'll try not
to do that but um okay so we're going to
choose a fantastic namespace for this
the namespace of course is going to be
Sparky so namespaces just basically let
us organize our code under our organ
kind of I guess packages and I don't
know just basically so that we don't get
conflicts with other libraries and
whatnot so we're going to be using the
Sparky namespace because that's the name
of this engine and then I'm also going
to put this into the graphics space
alright so there you go now Visual
Studio will desperately try to correct
me here but I'm going to have to fight
it so inside here I want to make a class
called window and that's probably it
well what we'll probably do is actually
we weren't enough enough
so inside window will have a width and a
height for makers where you need to make
it outside we could but anyway we've got
a width and height for our window
that's probably let's see we'll probably
also have a name for our window
so we'll probably eventually have to
create our own string class because I
don't like the standard one it's not
great but for now we'll just we'll roll
with this because I don't really want to
go on to that today so anyway on with
our window when we construct it we want
to pass in a name a width and a height
and that probably should be about enough
information to actually create the
window destructor wise I don't think we
really need anything yet so we'll leave
that there and we'll probably have an
update method here and let's see update
that'll be it for now anyway we'll start
implementing this stuff in a minute so
let's copy this let's make this include
window copy our name spaces in
all of this all this stuff and let's go
ahead and implement that constructor of
ours so I'm just going to copy the
parameters of course all right
so oh I'm actually going to use a proper
convention here so every field that is
private ok we won't do this for public
fields but private fields are going to
have a nice prefix of M in front of them
and an underscore just so that we
realize that they're actually members so
the M in this case is probably you
understand for member but just a quick
kind of prefix thing so whether we don't
necessarily have to do this dot or this
arrow name equals name we can just do
that right and so that we always are wet
we basically just have a nice
differentiation between local members
and local members or parameters and
actual fields okay so yeah we'll do that
because I want this engine to probably
be a bit a bit better written let's just
say so a lot of people also have
conventions for parameters as well like
there might prefix it with an A or
something I don't really like that so
I'm just going to do this yeah this is
my theme so if you want to I should
probably mention this yeah I just looked
at the chat there and broke the fourth
wall and now I'm going to distract
myself but this visual studio theme is
my video studio Center theme so if you
want to get it you just go to the Cherno
comm and I'm spelling this wrong /v s
all right and as you can see this will
graciously download for you and then you
can import it into visual studio by
going tools and import anyway there's a
video about this and that's episode 2 of
spikey so look at that if you're
confused but yeah this is my own theme
cool so anyway back to this so we're
going to do that with name and we're
also going to do this with with see this
is why I kind of like the fact that I'm
streaming this because um if I have any
questions that you guys might be having
well if you guys have any questions
while watching this and this is a just a
video on YouTube there's a possibility
they might get answered because there's
lot of people is like 100 people or
whatever watching this live who might
have the same questions and actually
have a chance to ask them while I'm
recording the video so it's pretty cool
it's pretty cool so we'll have that
destructor which will do absolutely
nothing as of now there's nothing to
destroy just yet
hmm and we'll have a will have our
update method all right awesome so make
sure we attach that constant in cool so
back to GL FLV did I close that again
and I'm getting bad at that lets Google
geo tag again go to the getting started
guide and look at this putting it
together section so all we really need
to do to make a window is we have this
wonderful pointer we set it equal to
that and we do a bunch of cool stuff I
want to have this on my other monitor
and just copy from it pretty much oops
so that's that is what's going to happen
so we'll include GL f w /g l fw three
will make our chillip w window pointer
window or tress a m window i probably
choose a convention for these things as
well I'll probably just tick with that
for now
what else those stuffs really all the
fields will actually need so back in
here and the Jets have stopped and you
guys watching the video will have no
idea what's going on but the Grand Prix
is on right now here in Melbourne so
there were these like f-18 jets flying
around making a lot of noise when I
started the stream but they're gone now
so that's nice anyway getting back to it
ah let's make an init method so private
methods I want to put down here so you
see how I've got to private blocks even
though I could have just put it there
that's just for organization purposes
again if I make a void here called init
it could have been up here and it would
have the exact same effect I just that
just looks weird having methods
members mixed up so I will make it down
here okay so in it will actually
initialize everything so we've set all
the things and then we're going to call
init okay so I could have just done that
in the constructor but I like having a
net method usually just so that we can
be all cool and everything so inside
here I'm going to actually make this
window so window equals jello W create
window with width height our awesome
title we've called it a name let's call
it title I didn't even think about that
when I was writing it to be honest but I
don't want to call it title because it's
been more I don't know usually window
titles are called window titles and not
window names so go out with and height
which of course I need to remember I'm
using this fantastic in your convention
and let's see we need on and the rest
apparently can be left at null so no so
null monitor and null share I don't want
to share this with anyone okay so that's
done so if the window fails we can
terminate it so I guess we'll just save
if not when I the window didn't work out
for us we'll just do something like
let's fail to create your little window
and we will return okay so how we could
even make this a bullet and return false
or something if it fails so let's go
into here quickly and just include
iostream okay so back to it so that's
what happens if our window it doesn't
work out
this is yelling at me because I forgot
the title or the M title what next on
which probably gel if w terminate as
well so let's make the contacts current
make contacts current for our window we
can set the swap interval to one that
should enable this and got on one vsync
we'll probably have to call it with some
hack to disable vsync anyway hopefully
she'll totally does that otherwise we'll
actually have to hack into that source
code and change it but key callbacks we
don't want that okay the other thing I
will have is in window H I do want to
have some kind of kind of are we closing
our window thing so bull closed Const
right so this will basically will have a
will have a boolean called em closed
right and then when it updates
it'll or whatever when it will pull the
events for something will actually be
able to set this true and then return it
so that outside and our game loop or in
the game engines game loop that can be
like oh the window just got closed so
that's our master plan so in this void
and is bull closed we'll just make it
here quickly so so I don't know I don't
know how GL FW does events such as that
so I don't remember at least apparently
it's got it's just got a GLW window
should close so we might we might not
even need that thing and what's wrong
with this it returns a boolean that's
what's wrong so we we might even just
return g left early window should close
I don't know we'll see if that works but
I'm hoping it does because then we
wouldn't even need the other thing
window should close all right so there
we go so hopefully that will work
next up so in update we want to
oh yes Ryan so yeah okay good
I've just remembered yeah I'll be a bit
better so let's swap the buffers I'll
explain what I'm thinking in a second
yeah so unlike SDL which requires you to
handle every event manually gel W will
just pull events and I think it will
register this as it has an actual event
so we shouldn't have any problems with
that is basically what I'm saying so
update will pull events and swap the
buffers and everything else should
pretty much work okay so in the
destruction for window we will have GL w
terminate because if we'll probably only
have one game window anyway so for when
I guess creator or whatever we
contaminate we need to grab our unit
code cut it and put it over here so if
it failed we can say something like fail
to initialize gel FLV obviously if it's
successful we don't need to do anything
and
okay so what we'll do instead of all
this is we will change this in it to be
able because we'll have multiple errors
we'll change it over here as well and
what we'll do is we'll if no it's not
what I meant keyboard if in it is false
so if that then probably just job W
terminate okay
so we'll have that here and then all we
have to do here is print our error
message and return false and that's all
we'll do right be nice and simple
so if how to initialize that and then
we'll trim of that all right cool and
then we'll return true at the end of
this so I think that's all we'll need in
terms of initialization which is
actually I think this thing sure job you
might actually be even simpler than STL
in terms of how to get things up there
which is cool so we've even got resizing
here and this is quite a nice document
yeah this is a great line of code here
by the way um this is a great little
thing here okay go so um don't think I
missed any useful chat messages here
no cool everything's good you guys are
all happy good yeah so that's that's how
kind of that's our window class right
now so it's pretty much I think it's at
the point where it's probably usable so
back in Maine what we're going to do is
well firstly we're going to include
source graphics and window I don't like
you backslashes someone changing of
false lashes but um will include window
I am going to say using namespace so you
can see this main is not Inland Sparky
namespace of course it doesn't need to
beat shouldn't be because there's not
part of the engine at all this is just
for testing purposes so what we will
need will used it both of these they're
actors in place so window window so will
go 800 by 600 why not and actually the
first thing is so
all right cool so we've created the
window so now our whole game loop is
simply while window dot closed is of
course false will simply window to
update okay and when the window gets to
here or whatever it will automatically
be terminated because the destructor
will run at the end of this and
everything will be fantastic so let's
look at this Aris so and it must return
a value yes it must so let's put in
return false all right fantastic so
we've got our window there's a close
button work yeah it does okay so we
should probably um okay so one thing you
can see here is that when we hit our
close button GL Toby doesn't terminate
because we've got that in the window
window destructor and the window object
won't be destroyed until after this this
this main function so it's getting to
system pause and the window still alive
so the point is that might be something
you want to think about you might want
to make it terminate as soon as the
close button is pressed because
otherwise it won't so you basically you
might because right now the window will
be actually be kept alive if you place
the close button it's actually up to
best to close it so you might want to
change that but if we get rid of this
system pause here and we run it and we
hit the close button it should close all
right so again just a consideration
thing we'll probably leave it as is
right now because there's no real need
to change it but we can change it later
okay cool so let's do a few opengl
things and make sure OpenGL is running
so and working correctly so I think gow3
might actually just wherein have to
include that all this but hopefully
opens year I think of lob does include
some kind of OpenGL like headers in it
so we won't have to include any other
header files but if I run something like
let's just after we create the context
of course GL clear color okay it is in
here so if we set it to something like a
really nice blue here right and run it
or flu we should see blue we see black
so investigation time so it looks like
make context current did indeed run for
our window and our window didn't fail
and being made so this is definitely
happening
we are swapping the buffers we're not
running clear though so that's probably
why so a GL clear color buffer it
alright fantastic
that's our clearance so into window I'm
going to actually make a clear method
again you could you could make your
books you could make your renderer do
this I'm probably going to make the
window do this though at least for now I
don't really see any downside with that
so avoid clear Const um let's see out
this will put closed at the bottom yeah
just organizing this stuff so again you
see how I put clear above update that's
just because clear is usually called
before updating so chronological stuff
so we'll clear the color buffer bit and
the depth buffer bits
all right so um make sure it has that GL
prefix okay cool so now yay did we have
a warning they're enforcing where's this
ah because it's an ant well well we
could that we'll probably fix it I'll
get rid of that warning probably the
easiest way anyway um cool so we've got
a window class now let's get some
information from OpenGL as to water on
earth is going on so if I call GL get
string gel version we should see what
version one so four point five fantastic
let's talk about glue and getting that
to work
because I think this is pretty much all
I wanted to do in terms of window right
now I'm just thinking we don't have
resizing or anything going on we could
resizing it actually really simple yes
it is so it is in fact let's put
resizing in right now because it's so
simple so right now if we resize it
it'll just work so that's fine because
it is clearing but once we have objects
in whatever more rendering geometry
let's let's actually do that so I'm
going to you you're you guys going to
see me use immediate mode for the only
time ever literally in this series but
if we jail begin GL triangles I don't
know how to do this this is old school
so um negative point five negative point
five then we'll put one at zero
and positive okay so oops I didn't put
the end Lowell GL and all right I don't
know what color is going to be but white
will do so there's our fantastic
triangle if we resize this it probably
won't yes you can see the triangles are
actually changing like it should be in
the middle and should be here right so
our windows and getting resized let's
make it do that
if we go in to update all we really need
to do is probably after we pull the
events I would imagine is we simply get
the frame buffer size for our window and
then we pass there now width and height
and as you can see that you get passed
in here as well they get passing by
reference which means that well this
function is going to actually change
them
what is up constant really is that not
what happens what's our width and height
well what are they doing here
so I'm um looking at the at the dock
width and height into width and height
well clearly that's fine I'll because
it's Const okay so no more constants for
you update goodbye I thought the
variable had to be constant like what
you're going to set it but it's constant
anyway it was confusing uh-huh
so let's see that's all good yeah so
this will set our width and height to
different values now so if we had some
gathers here such as and get width and
get height which actually will be Const
right and we'll probably just make these
in line why not
okay um so return em where and return em
height okay so I don't actually know if
inline will workers is expecting to
either probably be automatically in line
by the optimizer anyway but yeah so
essentially we're gonna be getting the
width and height to just to test this
out in line just means that it won't
actually result in a function call it'll
just return it it won't actually have to
call the function it'll basically paste
the function into where it gets called
but and that being said let's go ahead
and just grab our width and height so
window don't get wet window don't get
heights
all right cool so right now 800 by 600
if I modify this or whatever you can see
that once I let go it will adjust to
that new height so I will whip an height
so fantastic also I seem to be running a
lot of these goodbye alright so yeah
that's done all we have to do now is
just tell OpenGL to resizes viewport so
once we do that we can go ahead and call
a GL viewport to be 0 0 and then simply
M with Emma height and that's it so now
if we resize it pretty cool and resizes
along with us right now aspect ratio
gets kind of destroyed because of
whatever because while stretching it why
not
let's go ahead and create a better sized
window in 16:9 aspect ratio cool so
there we go we can do that ah and yes
good point mentioned by nor lick we
shouldn't be doing this in the update
method because that will happen
regardless of whether the window is
resized so what we should have is some
kind of resize callback so that this
currently runs when the window actually
gets resized I'm not sure like so the
jail of doubt that I keep closing it get
back here getting started so GL of W
actually do it in the update but that's
because this is just an example so I
don't actually know if there is a resize
callback there probably is
let's see here we go if you wish to be
notified when the window is resized then
there's set window size callback so
we'll just do that and it just it's that
alright fantastic so yeah we will
optimize this slightly here so we'll
make a private we already have a
pragmatic this might on this might not
want to be a private night we won't make
it I'm gonna make it here at all
we'll make it over here so avoid a
window resize so gel FW windows what it
wants a window into with height all
right fantastic so all we have to do
here is oh I think it does this part for
us anyway Lowell so we'll probably only
have to do this okay good so let's just
test this out to make sure it works and
we should set the current that's going
to be annoying because we have to set
the currents current windows thing will
arm will integrate that in just a second
so up here in in it I'll just simply
call gel W set window size call back to
our window resize alright now that's it
and for our window okay and that will
call that so if we run this and get our
builders okay so lets we could either
put it up top or we could just declare
it up here so I'll probably just do that
of course we need a parameter
happy go all right so now it should
still work as you can see so the only
downside here is that we're not setting
our actual like get this isn't really
runt like it's not our windows width and
height isn't actually being changed
because it's it's simply doing at its
opengl thing but the problem is it's not
changing this width and height at all
right we can't really make it do that
because this is a as you can see this is
not part of the window class right it's
it has no idea who the window is what
has idea of who this is but it doesn't
have any idea about who the what you
call it there's no idea who our window
is so several ways we could go around
this what we're going to leave this as
be right now we don't really need to
pull width and height all the time we
probably might in the future but yeah
but but for now we'll just leave it as
is because it's not really a problem
right now so for now width and height
will be our initial widths and Heights
okay be cool anyway so resizing is
working alright cool so let's get onto
glue you know what we're going to save
glue for next episode because it's
already 5:30 and I have to have to flee
so if you guys have any questions I'm
basically going to open up the chat
right now for any questions so that we
can ask away but this is our fantastic
window with some OpenGL immediate mode
embarrassing but um we'll set up glue
next episode which should be tomorrow so
I'm going to stream tomorrow at the same
time maybe around probably around them
let's see probably around 3:30 ish p.m.
my time maybe 4 p.m. my time so that's
really nice in standard time but yeah so
there's our fantastic window any
questions why did you use a triangle and
not a rectangle asks re-ack well that
was a very big mistake on my part
so we're going to change that now well
the actual reason was because it has
less vertices and thus it would
theoretically be faster for me to do
that but since we're not in that mode
anymore we can ignore that so let's
change this a bit
no that's not what I meant so that
that's that and that is all right only
time will tell
yes so there's a rectangle now which is
amazing okay um how many words per
minute do I type I don't know about 100
ish yeah that's looks like everything
everyone everything else is um is pretty
much clear so there's our engine it's
the beginnings of so I will put this on
github so right over here
we'll have a Sparky Engine repository
and all this code will be there which
will be awesome and then tomorrow we'll
take a look at integrating glue and
actually using some modern OpenGL and
from then on we'll just move on to
basically creating standard abstractions
for OpenGL so that's kind of the plan
right
tomorrow we'll implement glue and then
and make sure that we can use in
whatever everything set up correctly and
then from then we'll move on to
abstracting OpenGL into this engine so
that we can create stuff like shaders
and textures easily and draw objects
easily and yeah we'll just get on with
the rendering engine so um thanks for
watching guys if you guys were watching
the actual YouTube video have any
who have any questions just ask them and
leave comment below and then I'll
probably ask them next video especially
because these videos are going to be
pretty frequent so there'll be no
problem with that okay cool so yeah
thanks watching guys and I'll see you
next time goodbye
you